politique toujours avec cette visite qui
aurait pu passer inaperçue valérie
pécresse la candidate heller à la
présidentielle était en touraine ce
matin un passage éclair sur la
thématique de la justice est la
présidente de la région ile de france
s'est notamment rendu à la maison
d'arrêt de tours pour évoquer son plan
de sauvetage de la justice 9 milliards
d'euros pour doter les tribunaux et les
prisons de plus de personnel romain
delville la candidate heller valérie
pécresse après s'être rendu à huis clos
au tribunal de tours et à la maison
d'arrêt de la rue henri-martin fustige
le bilan justice d' emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron n'a pas tenu ses
promesses il laisse notre système
judiciaire dans un état désastreux
seulement 2000 places de prison ont été
construites sur les 15000 promise
seulement 20 centres éducatifs fermés
ont été créés sur les 56 promis je veux
faire de ma présidence celle de
l'impunité zéro et pour ce faire je vais
très en place un plan de sauvetage et de
modernisation de la justice plus de
moyens pour plus de sanctions valérie
pécresse veut des peines plancher pour
les récidivistes violent pour les
agresseurs de députés de policiers ou
encore de pompiers pour la candidate de
droite la justice est aujourd'hui le
maillon faible de la sécurité en france
je veux augmenter de plus de 50 % sur
cinq ans les moyens décrivent une eau
pour les porter à 9 milliards d'euros
par an j'augmenterais depuis le 50% le
nombre de magistrats avec l' embauche de
3000 juge 2000 procureur mais pour que
ce plan puisse être opérationnel je
recruterai aussi 3000 greffier 5000
juriste assistants et 3000 personnel
technique
son objectif déclaré une justice plus
rapide et plus ferme avec les
délinquants